You know what they say, wetter is better,
and that’s true in the hunt for extraterrestrial
life.
But where else is water in our solar system
besides Earth?
Hey guys, Julia here for DNews.
We keep searching for liquid water on other
planets because we think it’s a key ingredient
for life as we know it.
But maybe we’re wrong, Amy talked about
how life might look on other planets in another
video.
Check it out, there’s a link in the description.
But tell Mulder to rejoice!
Recent research found strong evidence of liquid
water, adding two new candidates to the list
of potentials hosts of life.
In the 1990s researchers found some strange
magnetic readings taken by NASA's Galileo
spacecraft of one of Jupiter’s moons Ganymede.
They theorized that a layer of thick salty
liquid water was the best explanation.
Now, new images from NASA’s Hubble Space
Telescope has the best evidence for it.
The research, published in Journal of Geophysical
Research: Space Physics looked at images of
the moon’s magnetic field.
Ganymede is rare, in that it’s the only
known moon with its own magnetic field.
This field “rocks” back and forth whenever
Jupiter’s magnetic field changes.
This rocking motion allowed scientists to
estimate how much water might exist on the
Jovian moon.
They estimate an ocean ten times deeper than
Earth’s underneath a thick layer of ice,
which might make it inhabitable to life.
But wait!
Don’t get too disappointed, there’s more
water - A recent study published in the journal
Nature found evidence of hot water flowing
on Enceladus, one of Saturn’s moons.
Liquid water was long suspected, in 2005 the
Cassini spacecraft captured images of water
plumes spewing from the surface.
But this new study analyzed tiny rock bits
from the moon, and found them filled with
salt and silica.
Silica is so similar to quartz and sand, which
are formed in hydrothermal vents, that the
finding suggests hot water is currently flowing
on the moon.
Hydrothermal vents on Enceladus would be a
huge discovery.
A lot of scientists currently think that life
on Earth got its start in deep sea hydrothermal
vents.
If these vents exists on other planets…
well they’d be a good place to look for
extraterrestrial life.
Other celestial bodies might have water, too.
As far back as 1997, NASA has thought Europa,
another moon of Jupiter’s, has a giant ocean.
Images captured from a flyby of the Galileo
Spacecraft suggested as much.
But the water might be trapped beneath a thick
layer of ice which some scientists say is
“bad for biology.”
Another popular candidate for extraterrestrial
life, Mars!
It’s no secret Mars has icy polar regions.
But scientists have wondered for a while now
whether or not the planet was wetter in the
past.
New research published in the journal Science
suggests that 4.5 billion years ago, the red
planet might have had an ocean 450 feet deep.
The truth, might still be out there.
So what do you think?
Is wetter really better?
Let us know in the comments below.
While you’re at it don’t forget to hit
those like and subscribe buttons and keep
coming back here for new episodes every day
of the week